for more than three months this Corridor
through the Black Sea has been a
humanitarian Lifeline the UN says about
9 million tons of grain has been
transported and it says despite Russia
suspending its participation after the
Ukrainian drone attack on its Fleet the
scheme will continue they have suspended
they haven't withdrawn
they have suspended and they haven't
terminated and the difference is the
difference is very very simple the
difference is that as parties to that
Black Sea grain initiative they are
still Bound by it but Russia's defense
Ministry issued a statement saying the
fact that the grain cargo ships were
still using the Black Sea route was
unacceptable that followed these
comments from Russia's ambassador to the
UN
the Russian side cannot guarantee the
safety of Civilian vessels participating
in the Black Sea initiative
we cannot allow an unimpeded passage of
vessels without our inspection and we
will have to undertake our own measures
to control what was allowed by The Joint
coordination Center without our consent
we will provide details on our
conclusions and our approaches to this
in the very near future there are big
problems ahead for the UN how will
insurance companies react and what will
shipping firms do if premiums Skyrocket
it's also worth noting that the deal is
only supposed to last until the 18th of
November will Russia now agree to extend
it James Bay's Al Jazeera of the United
Nations